bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire je reçois aujourd'hui alain
deneault pour son livre baume de colomb
au portrait du colonisateur et au
portrait du colonisé il ajoute le
portrait du côlon et c'est pas piqué des
vers le gars schmidt qui raconte son
enfance en urss dans supreme soviets et
cyril pittman l'auteur de quelle mouche
l'a piqué c'est sur les spécificités des
artistes plastiques des haines des 60
dernières années
mais on commence tout de suite par ce
qui caractérise notre époque
voici les réponses de nos invités en
images on commence par là votre ciel
pittman c'est une oeuvre de qui alors
c'est une oeuvre de malachi farrell que
j'expose en ce moment rare et c'est vrai
que j'ai trouvé que c'était un très très
bon symbole par rapport à l'époque dans
lequel on vivait c'est à dire qu'il fait
ses dessins l'exposa belle qu'ovide les
poches et les il fait des dessins sur
des masques et les vend cher mais il est
vengeurs non ils vivent 400 euros ah ben
ça va ça va olga schmitt votre image à
vous
c'est également une oeuvre d'art alors
dites-nous de qu'il s'agit il s'agit
d'un tableau de l'aide celle qu'offre
qui en 1960 a fait le portrait d'un
visage d'homme et qui finalement sans
penser à mal à dessiner l'humanité toute
entière non pas à naître
non pas à naître en particulier me
l'humanité tout entière et c'est ça qui
me plaît beaucoup c'est un tableau qui
s'appelle les mangeurs de tête où je
pense que ça parle
formidablement de de l'instant présent
et c'est ça qui m'intéresse c'est à dire
que c'est cette pérennité cette lame de
fond qui traverse l'humanité depuis
qu'elle existe non pas à l'époque mais
l'instant présent parce que l'époque est
toujours la même pour moi c'est à dire
que depuis la la grotte de lascaux
l'ailé les fresques égyptiennes et elke
hoff dans son appartement communautaire
à moscou l'humanité et sa féroce tendre
perdu et dangereuse et en même temps
fascinante
il faut ajouter que de celles qu'offrent
et à des personnages de votre livre on
en reparlera donc que tout à l'heure
puisque c'est le compagnon de votre mère
j'ai grandi j'ai grandi avec ces avec
ses tables voilà et les voilà les
anecdotes ça vous voyez et les aventures
et de celles qu'offrent qui sont utiles
sont là aussi mériterait un livre elle
toute seule enfin l un de nos votre
image à vous c'est également une oeuvre
d'art c'est un petit thème radars ça
serait beaucoup dire c'était un objet
commercial vendus dans le réseau de la
grande distribution au canada et aux
états unis qui résume bien ce qu'il en
est de la domination culturelle au
canada par un régime colonial à savoir
qu'on a là une synthèse kitsch entre ce
que les premières nations ont produit
dans l'ouest du territoire c'est-à-dire
des totems l' amalgame et à une série de
symboles sur le sport professionnel on
voit surtout une manifestation crispé de
violence de la part de personnages qui
sont au centre du bibelot mais le tout
coiffé d'une mascotte souriante il nous
invite à ne pas prendre au sérieux ce
qui est présenté là sous la forme d'une
récupération culturel et bien commençons
alain deneault vous êtes philosophe vous
êtes canadien et vous publiez bande de
colon chez lux éditeur un livre qui a
fait beaucoup de bruit au québec
alors de quoi s'agit-il et bien au
portrait du colonisateur et au portrait
du colonisé dressé autrefois par albert
memmi mais aussi par jean paul sartre
dans sa préface aux damnés de la terre
le livre de franz fanon vous ajouter ici
un portrait du côlon c'est la figure
manquantes dites vous on a commencé à
parler d'eux on a on a abordé la
question du colonialisme au québec à
partir des années 60 en important les
catégories qu'avait développé albert
memmi dans ces deux portraits les
catégories du colonisateur du côlon en
enfermant la conscience politique qui
était la nôtre à ce moment là dans cette
dialectique ans il y avait de nous par
les colonisateurs qu'on voyait comme
étant bon les britanniques le pouvoir
financier américain et européen
étrangers et des colonisés qui aurait
été à ce moment-là les québécois et les
canadiens français sans fond considérer
une figure pourtant central qui est
entre les deux
qui est le côlon et le côlon ont foncé
si on s'y arrête
une figure qui mérite d'être étudiée non
seulement au canada mais dans plusieurs
situations historiques et sociales
l'afrique du nord par exemple israël
haïti bon et le colon qu'est ce que
c'est c'est c'est l'acteur social qui ne
fait pas partie les colonisateurs qu'on
pourrait associer aujourd'hui 1% ou à
une oligarchie le colonisateur c'est
l'acteur social le grand actionnaire le
gestionnaire de société à charte qui a
le pouvoir de façonner la colonie d'en
élaborer les termes dans élaboré le
fonctionnement ce n'est pas celui-là le
colon le colon c'est le subalterne qui
réalise le dessin coloniale en
effectuant les basses besognes qui lui
corresponde ce sont les petites mains
l'action coloniale au détriment des
colonisés qui lui est complètement
marginalisé comme la même il a bien
décrit c'est à dire en ce qui concerne
le canada les peuples d'origine
on désigne aussi comme les temps les
premières nations c'est à dire les cris
les innu les micmacs les hurons qui ont
été surtout à partir de la colonisation
britannique
parqués dans des réserves dans ce que
l'on peut appeler un génocide à petit
feu quand on voit dans l'effacement
démographique de ces populations là et
le côlon au fond c'est le sujet qui
arrive mal à se penser conclut
aujourd'hui identifiées dans un flou
stérile à une classe moyenne mais qui au
fond est confronté à son rôle historique
fort peu glorieux à savoir collaborer
avec les puissants dans le but
d'échapper au sort des plus faibles sans
pour autant tirer d'une part un grand
dividendes de cette collaboration là et
aussi sans disposer d'un pouvoir ou
d'une autonomie d'une souveraineté qui
en fait un citoyen en lisant votre livre
je me disais au fond les colons c'est ce
sont surtout ceux qui sont nés bien
après la conquête bien après la
colonisation
on pourrait dire ça de tous les
québécois aujourd'hui ils n'ont pas eu à
conquérir ce pays est la force des armes
ils se hissent on est il dit sonné ils
ont toujours été chez eux dans ce pays
et c'est ce qui ferait la différence
entre le colon et le colonisateur on
aurait pu dire sale la même chose des
français en algérie des afrikaners en
afrique du sud
vous vous dites non il ya quand même
encore aujourd'hui des colonisateurs
ce sont les riches sont les possédants
ce sont ceux qui disposent de la
souveraineté sur la colonie on pourrait
dire que ce sont jamais que des colons
qui se sont enrichis d'écolo qui ont
réussi non la catégorie colons
et ne fait pas l'objet d'une prise de
conscience vive les colons n'arrive
maariv mal à se penser c'est une
catégorie qui n'apparaît pas dans le
discours
vous savez que chez nous par exemple
l'expression collant est une injure
alors bon sol et au physique du japon va
crier dans la rue quelques qui serait je
ne sais trop vulgaire bon et polie je ne
sais trop en dire mais les espèces de
colomb quoi alors qu'on entendrait
jamais aux états unis ou en france
quelque accuser quelqu'un d'autre d'être
citoyen et pour de bon en belgique de
dire un sujet du roi quoi pour injurier
quelqu'un et on pense à témoin un vrai
malaise par rapport aux statuts le
statut de colomb grand mal à l'aise on
arrive on en arrive ma la seule la tribu
et à prendre conscience de ce que nous
avons nous avons ici ou ailleurs
à ce titre j'ai analysé le cas du canada
mais je crois que si en afrique du nord
ou en afrique du sud ou dans d'autres
régions du monde on analysait aussi le
statut du côlon on observera le titre le
nom de ce malaise peut-être sauf en
israël qui fait que ces petits ongles à
lui le côlon se revendique comme telle
mais c'est une exception et et je pense
que le travail des intellectuels
anticolonialiste des années 50-60 je
pense notamment à elle permis à ces
portraits du colonisateur est que le
venise et ont joué beaucoup on comptait
beaucoup dans cette espèce d'effacement
du statut du côlon rappelle que chez
albert memmi ya pas vraiment de colomb
et un colonisateur et lorsque le colon
apparaît parce qu'on le voit passer de
temps en temps c'est la même chose chez
sartre il
il est petit assimilés aux colonisateurs
tout simplement parce que la proche de
mami est davantage psychologique
en ce qui l'intéresse c'est d'analyser
une attitude une attitude coloniale que
colonisatrice coloniale qui refont vaut
autant pour bon le grand actionnaire
d'entreprises qui façonnent laplaud n'y
fait main basse sur les richesses bon
aussi organisant l'administration
coloniale en sa législation son droit sa
police bon son autorité et et le
colonisateur 20 le colon pour mes miss
est celui qui ont fait six co
logiquement symboliquement
intellectuellement s'assimile
au colonisateur de manière abusive os
abuse lui même et on fasse souvent
sachez le colombien le colon il est chez
nous il est en quelque sorte toujours en
train de basculer dans une catégorie où
une autre soit il ce fantasme
colonisateur parce que il est de la race
au sens littéral la des puissants il est
l'europe 1 face aux indigènes aux
autochtones aux premières nations ou
peuple d'origine ou bien parfois il peut
arriver s'il a perdu la main dans
l'aventuré coloniale c'est le cas des
français après la conquête britannique
de 1760 chez nous elle a tout d'un coup
on se s'assimile aux colonisés ondima
finalement nous nous avons été deux
vaincus bafouée prolétarisés c'est ce
qu'il faudrait dire en fête et on oublie
à ce moment là les colonisés véritable
que sont les premières nations et mais
le colon c'est celui qui arrive mal à se
dire parce que son rôle
on fond dans l'histoire et à ses actes
et ses plus glorieux quoi c'est à dire
qu'est ce que c'est comme collomb c'est
ce qu'on pourrait cesser ce sont tous
ceux et toutes celles aujourd'hui qui
s'associe à la classe moyenne
heikki qui se vit au fond et se perd
dans une catégorie qui veut pas dire
grand chose mais que le colon qu'est ce
que c'est ce sont les les subalternes de
l'entreprise coloniale week end amusant
enfin ce qu'il ya d'intéressant je pense
chez les québécois c'est quand même un
cas très particulier parce qu'ils ont
été colonisateurs au début c'était le
temps de la nouvelle france puis ensuite
ils sont colonisées par les britanniques
un siècle plus tard et au fond vous le
dites vous-même aujourd'hui il voudrait
s'assimiler aux indiens au native
de ce territoire et c'est les indiens
c'est le peuple frère il se vit comme à
coloniser plus du tout comme un colon je
dirais plutôt qu'on cherche à raturer
l'existence des colonisés véritable et à
se substituer à eux on dit en fait y'a
on droit à penser si on irrite du modèle
de mê me on doit penser sur un mode
dialectique si on n'est pas colonisateur
on est donc colonisés et on va se penser
comme tel alors que bon mon invitation
consiste à prendre conscience de la
catégorie du côlon aussi en tant qu elle
est l et ramifié de dire qu'on est il
n'y a pas un idéal type du côlon qui
vaut pour tout le monde c'est à dire que
le colon il peut être autant au fond
prolétarisés du siv le pêcheur acadienne
pêcheurs gaspésiens qui est complètement
à la solde des grands investisseurs de
les gérer dans le domaine de la pêche et
qui ne peut pas se sortir la spirale de
l'endettement mais les colons quand même
dans la mesure où il peut encore
participer à ce régime là essayer au fil
des générations de dégager un plus
d'autonomie de trouver niche bond de
participer quand même à l'activité
industrielle ans qui est la visée même
essentiel de l'économie de la colonie
alors que le colonisé lui il est
marginalisé d'une manière absolue c'est
à dire qu'il est dans sa réserve
il est au mieux assister au pire
abandonné et dessus et un par le
processus colonial et y aura par
ailleurs dans l'autre bon à l'autre
extrémité de l'éventail de figure
possibles du côlon ben le bon celui qui
fait partisan de la classe moyenne aisée
en qu'ils aient eu des premiers
exécutant a eu un des premiers vous des
rondes et des premiers vont experts
capables de bombes de prêter sa force de
travail à ceux qui façonnent la colonie
mais la colonie d'abord et avant tout
elle et elle est un projet industriel
une entreprise ans a été dans le cas de
la nouvelle france la compagnie descente
à ce stade ce qui était sinon à l'époque
britannique des sociétés à chartes
d'abord et ensuite des entreprises
privées puissant qui avait le pouvoir de
faire main basse sur les richesses
coloniale de les exploiter au profit de
marchés étrangers et donc d'organiser la
vie coloniale en fonction de ce projet
commercial et industriel et de compter
sur 7 7 catégories intermédiaires que
sont les colons ce délai petit mais ce
sont ceux qui qui prient pour qu'un
investisseur viennent créer des emplois
c'est ce sont ceux qui en france
souhaite simplement dans le pouvoir
d'achat se content d administrer ce ne
sont pas des citoyens qui se voit comme
porteur d'une souveraineté devant être
reflétés dans des décisions
institutionnelles d'une donnée
république si on veut se référer aux
modèles conceptuels le poisson ce sont
des gens qui se contentent d'être là bon
dans une sorte de droit qui est très
individuelle quoi très libérale et qui
consiste réellement essayé de dégager un
petit avantage au fait d'être là au
détriment des colonisés qu'on a
complètement oublié ça c'est difficile
de penser ça en france
parce qu'en france liestal aventure
coloniale française majoritairement n'en
a pas été une de peuplement ce qu'on a
fait comme on était dans des pays chauds
d'une part et d'autre part la république
ne tenait pas plus que ça ah bon donc
bon lui dire déplacer des populations
qui aurait été excédentaire comme
c'était le cas au royaume uni on a
plutôt transformé les colonisés en colon
c'est à dire qu'on a en quelque sorte
par le travail forcé par la violence par
des bons des histoires boy minable en
est en quelque sorte mis à disposition
du pouvoir colonisateur des colonisés
qui se sont mis à travailler dans des
conditions encore une fois très souvent
difficile et les colons étaient
finalement fort peu nombreux dans les
colonies à la française parce que
c'était finalement dit carrade en des
ddd des relais du pouvoir et comme le
dit le 10 mai mis des gens assez
médiocre ans qu'il préférait avoir dans
la colonie quelques domestique puis d
une grande ville avec des avantages que
de retourner ensuite
plutôt que de retourner dans l'hexagone
à vivre comme tout le monde en faisant
la queue dans les marchés quoi bon donc
là il y avait comme un petit avantage
qui est l etat qui était observé mais on
n'a pas eu c'est ce phénomène de 2,2
d'un déplacement massif de population
comme ça a été le cas au canada où là
les colons sont devenus majoritaires sur
un plan démographique et c'est très
important d'avoir en tête ce modèle là
canadien parce qu' il n'est pas du tout
je dirais marginal concernant ce qu'on
pourrait penser pourrait penser que là
on fait un petit bloc canada c'est un
peu exotique on va passer à autre chose
il faut savoir que le modèle canadien
est d'abord et avant tout une réussite
un du référent coloniale britannique qui
lui a eu un impact majeur dans la
géopolitique moderne il faut voir que
aujourd'hui l'irak par exemple qui fait
suite au démantèlement de l'empiré
ottoman après la première guerre
mondiale a été développé en sous la
forme d'un mandat britannique
exactement avec pour modèle le canada
l'irak c'est un canada pétroliers en
c'est à dire c'est une colonie qui vit
strictement de par ses institutions de
par son câble à favoriser l'exploitation
de richesses au profit de marchés
étrangers
li représentants politiques étant la
plus tôt pour rebond symboliser une
sorte de ronde administrations locales
plus comme un conseil municipal
voici vous voulez c'est exactement la
même chose avec le congo de léopold ii
le congo de léopold ii avait pour moi
mon modèle
l'administration de l'île de java qui
est elle aussi reposer sur des des
modalités britannique en comme
l'australie comme le canada est situé
lorsqu'il s'agissait de faire c'est
créer une vaste zone où des entreprises
grâce à une administration adaptés
peuvent extraire ce qu'ils veulent au
détriment des colonisés avec pour force
d'appoint et des colons qui sont là pour
bon s'assurer que le fonctionnement de
l'exploitation à courre est évidemment
au bénéfice de colonisateurs qui sont
aujourd'hui on dirait les 1% les
oligarques voile et les grands
affairistes qui eux au fond d'eux ne ne
sont même pas éventuellement sur le
territoire
il nous reste deux minutes
mais je voudrais que vous disiez amoa
l'un de nos deux de l'île mystérieuse de
jules verne parce que vous en parler
longuement dans le livre vite au fossat
c'est une hagiographie du côlon oui tout
à fait c'est à dire que c'est jules
verne c'est formidable parce qu'on a là
la lecture française du côlon fantasmer
pourquoi parce que bon c'est l'histoire
d'un jeu lui vient ce sont des
américains à l'époque de la guerre de la
cc de sécession qui sont emportés
demeure complètement fantastique sur
dans une montgolfière jusque sur une île
du pacifique
et là il arrive qu'ils sont cinq sur une
île du pacifique et laventure le
naufrage dans lequel ils sont ne les
transforme pas ne les transforme pas du
tout c'est à dire que vous y arrives for
tous des hommes forts de leurs
compétences en un ingénieur évidemment
physiciens et ingénieurs qui est
l'espèce de maître à penser du groupe
ensuite un journaliste est une sorte
d'honnête homme un peu omniscient
pourront cultiver quelques bricoleurs
puis est ce qu un ancien esclave qui
aimait tellement sont même pas été
capable de s'en séparer 110 non plus une
sorte d' apprenti et les cinq sur l'île
se revendique colons et lille ne les
transforme jamais mais eux ils
transforment lille il transforme lille
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
que ben il met son sont ces écosystèmes
sa faune de sa flore complètement sous
leur autorité et surtout dans la
toponymie
il désigne les lieux à partir de
références américaines tant que jamais
ils vont par exemple va appeler par
exemple un chemin le chemin des cailloux
ou je sais pas moi la plage de la
montagne en fonction du lieu
le lieu jamais ne les atteint e
transforme le lieu et on pourrait et le
statut du côlon qui est revendiquée dans
le livre un toujours verne qui narre son
histoire d les colons les colons fait
ceci les colons sont allés là bas les
colons abad sud est ce un jeu les
beaumont les colons sont toujours vu
comme n'ayant pas de colonisateurs ce
qui est une sorte de fantasme quoi aussi
bondée des lumières peut-être sur la
raison qui va en blanc l'a emporté sur
la nature il ya peut-être parfois des
des peuples
origine sur les mots on les voit pas
puis ce sont toujours des menaces il
faudra venir à bout bon on pourrait se
dire bon de toucher rectal fantasmer
faut savoir que je le verbe a par
ailleurs écrit un autre vraiment qui
porte aussi sur des colons et là on a un
peu la même le même rapport au monde des
colons qui se prétendent bon livre qui
exploite tout bon pied et c'est sur le
canada c'est la famille sans monde
commente gilbert nous là on raconte
comment des acadiens et ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui des québécois se sont vus
privés
après la conquête britannique du grand
projet colonial du dd le leur même s'il
avait avait eu les coudées franches et
on vend vous quelle est l'analyse
l'idéologie en kit à l'origine de ce
pays le canada mais aussi de l'australie
et de tous les rejetons directs et
indirects que l' empire britannique a
produit dans la modernité
on ferait bien de s'intéresser ça
s'intitule bande de colons c'est signé
alain deneault ces sous-titrés mauvaise
conscience de classe etc paru aux
éditions lux on se retrouve juste après
la pause
olivier schmitt vous êtes depuis belle
lurette une figure de la vie parisienne
mais avant d'arriver en france j'avais
grandi en urss c'est ce que vous
racontez dans suprême soviets qui vient
de paraître chez le pas d'oiseau avec
une préface d'emmanuel carrère un livre
drôlement bien écrit d'ailleurs je vous
félicite beaucoup mieux que tous les ans
tous les cas que la plupart des prix
littéraires souvent très drôle très
mélancolique
qu'est ce qui reste encore aujourd'hui
de soviétiques en vous qui reste de
soviétiques je dirais en réalité vous
savez je pense que toutes les choses qui
se passent se passe dans l'enfance
après ça passe c'est tout après on
construit on se construit
mais ce qui reste en moi de soviétique
c'est les 15 premières années de ma vie
qui se sont passées donc à moscou dans
une famille extrêmement haute en
couleurs une famille étonnante puisque
mes parents étaient loin de moi je les
voyais très peu
j'ai été élevée par une grand-mère
aviatrice militaire qui a fait toute la
guerre et qui m'a élevée au son des des
chansons de guerre soviétiques et les
films que j'ai regardé jusqu'à l'âge de
15 ans était en noir et blanc c'était
des films de guerre
c'était ce qui en france est comme ça
voilà le quand passent les cigognes et 1
et la palme d'or à cannes en 1958 je
crois et bien c'est est un film que ma
grand mère et moi regardions très
souvent on passait le sait l'un des
rares films soviétiques qu'on a pu voir
après la seconde guerre mondiale c'est
un grand chef-d'oeuvre de calais 2 off
mais vous citez effectivement plein de
ses chefs d'oeuvre absolu de colo taux
aux offres
oui et c'est sait il y à il y avait
évidemment quand passent les cigognes et
du film connu en occident mais vous
imaginez que en russie en union
soviétique
après 20 millions de morts de la guerre
les films de guerre étaient ils avaient
des chefs d'oeuvre absolu comme la
ballade du soldat l'ailé mais on film
qui se passait sur le front stalingrad
et c'est donc j'ai été ce qui reste de
soviétiques en moi c'est ça c'est à dire
c'est une grande conscience d armand de
la csn c'est une forme de rigueur morale
curieusement voilà sans doute d'avoir
été élevé par une militaire qui arrête
on nous sert d'ailleurs comment
arrêtons-nous sur vague grenoble parce
qu'après avoir lu votre livre j'ai
l'impression de l'avoir connu et d'avoir
un peu vécu elle était partie le riz a
adoré il était pilote pendant la seconde
guerre mondiale puis le tête des
iliouchine elles étaient bardés de
médailles
elle était devenue directrice d'école
c'est un personnage absolument
incroyable votre corps meurt alors
souvent les petites filles ont tendance
à les idéaliser vous vous avez vécu
toute votre vie avec votre grand mère
j'ai vécu toute ma vie avec ma
grand-mère et vous ne pensez pas si bien
dire puisque j'ai vécu avec ma grand
mère jusqu'à son dernier souffle
c'était une femme d'une dent caractère
très étonnant elle était très masculines
et elles vivent et surtout elle a vécu
une histoire incroyable que j'ai apprise
il ya très peu de temps c'est qu'elle a
vécu toute sa vie avec une femme dont je
pensais qu'elle était ma tante est cette
femme était en fait son amoureuse donc
pendant
cinquante ans je pensais avoir été
élevée par un couple de vieilles filles
qui n'ont pas connu les trains qui n'ont
pas connu l'amour qui était comme ça un
peu gauche dans les sentiments et en
fait j'étais un j'ai été élevée par un
couple d'amoureux zh il ya également
d'autres
il ya également votre mère donc la fille
de votre grand-mère alors elle est
comédienne elle est célèbre allé très
très belle
elle vous tient pas la distance mais
elle est tout le temps là quand elle
arrive elle vous gâte c'est la russe
parfaite
aa c'est un cetain je ne le savais pas à
l'époque mais aujourd'hui je me rends
compte que c'est un personnage c'est
presque un cliché de la femme russe
c'est à dire qu'elle était d'abord elle
était incroyablement belle elle n'était
pas mince elle avait une fête rime très
généreuse et elle avait une espèce de
bonté au poids comme ça pour
pratiquement tout le monde l'adorait les
gens elle adore toujours les gens et je
faisais partie de ces victimes si je
puis dire c'est à dire qu elle
lorsqu'elle veut voyez ce qui était très
rare mais quand elle me voyait elle mais
elle met tout fait sur sa danse est sain
et me me faisais la cuisine et il me
regardait toujours avec amour et je
pensais vraiment que que ça allait durer
et puis ça s'arrêtait ça s'est arrêté
brusquement et je j'ai été renvoyé chez
ma grand-mère occire aussi rapidement et
aussi facilement que j'en avais été
enlevé deux jours avant par exemple
j'allais voir j'allais chez mes parents
comme d'autres aller chez leurs grands
parents justement alors votre père il
était metteur en scène il était connu
mais lui c'est le prototype a peu de
l'intellectuel est lunettes qui est pas
forcément très bien vus en russie est
pas tellement plus on avance et il sait
il aime bien les potes mais il faut
qu'ils font des bruits qui veut aider
voilà exactement exactement il es t il
et c'est aussi une forme de prototype
comme ça de de l'élève provincial il est
arrivé de minsk à moscou et ça c'est
très particulier aussi de l'union
soviétique de l'époque ma mère qui vient
du fin fond de sibérie a fait là guy
thys la grande école de théâtre mon père
pareil qui venait vraiment de la
province en bélarussie les deux ont eu
accès à la plus au conservatoire on peut
dire en france et le conservatoire de
paris sans aucun piston avec des
enfin je veux dire voilà ça c'est une
particularité comme même du système
soviétique à l'époque c'est que c'est
que tout le monde pouvait prétendre ce
n'était pas un rêve que d'arriver dans
la capitale est de faire de faire ses
classes
donc mon père effectivement cumuler un
peu parce que non seulement c'était
pourtant un beau garçon mais il était
juif
il avait des lunettes il était chétif et
il lisait autant à moitié enrhumé ce qui
est ce qui rendait ma grand mère qui
était une espèce de domme de la famille
malade puisque elle le regardait
toujours avec énormément de pitié et en
même temps une certaine crainte puisque
elle voyait bien que toujours le nez
fourré dans les livres il devait pas
être idiot mais elle en était quand même
un peu désolé pour ma mère elle disait
toujours mais enfin ce garçon n'est pas
capable de boire ça s'entend au sens
sans s'évanouir
comment comme on veux tu traverses et à
vie avec lui
elle a bien vu puisque ils n'ont pas
très bien c'est la vie ensemble
il sort ils sont séparés en est et va
être remplacé par partie celle qu'offre
l'est de celle qu'offre le peintre dont
vous avez parlé au début de cette
émission qui lui est une espèce de
rockstar en union soviétique à l'époque
à lui c'est une rockstar c'est une rock
star
encore aujourd'hui quand il arrive à
moscou il n'est pas rare qu'il soit
entouré de jeunes gens qui lui demande
un autographe
oui c'est une espèce et sans le savoir
c'est à dire que c'est quelqu'un qui a
vécu toute sa vie sans avoir de rapports
finalement avec le monde extérieur
et d'ailleurs ça m'a toujours étonné
j'ai toujours beaucoup aimé ça
quand je lui disais mais oleg et eu
besoin d'inspiration pour peindre il me
disait toujours mais quelle inspiration
il n'a jamais eu besoin par exemple du
monde extérieur il n'a jamais eu besoin
de voyager
de voir le clair de lune lorsqu'il pleut
je ne parle pas aujourd'hui il fait beau
au contraire je suis inspiré rien du
tout il m'a toujours dit j'ai besoin de
neuf mètres carrés aller à l'époque à
moscou il vivait dans une tourner et
pour voir son fameux tableau qui
s'appelle la scène d'où dont vous avez
parlé tout à l'heure d'ailleurs of g il
ay là pour pour peindre ce tableau qui
aujourd'hui considéré comme un
chef-d'oeuvre de la russe contemporain
pour le regarder de loin il était obligé
de prendre une paire de jumelles et de
la retourner pour avoir assez de recul
puisque puisque il peignait ce tableau
coucher voilà il n'y avait pas de place
dans la dans la dans l'âge d'or dans la
chambre vos parents et collègues sont
pas vraiment des dissidences et enfin
votre mère votre pause éléments l'ex est
pas vraiment des dissidents c'est les
gens qui sont un peu en marge comme
c'est ma grand mère ma grand mère non
seulement c'est pas une dissidente mais
ma grand mère était et est vrai que la
période jusqu'à la moelle
une vraie patriote elle adorait l'union
soviétique elle adorait son pays elle a
vu elle a quand même fait la guerre elle
est née en 1900 ans donc elle est parti
à la guerre à 21 ans et elle en est
venue à 25
donc je vous imaginez ce qu'ont vu ses
yeux c'est alors qu'est ce que vous
décrivez avec beaucoup d'humour
le dh vite ce sont les appartements
communautaires on en a beaucoup pourtant
dû parler nous en occident mais on
n'arrive pas bien à se représenter ce
que c'est des grands appartements
bourgeois qu'on va diviser
après la révolution
en gros 10 mètres carrés par personne et
on s'est toujours demandé mais commence
à fonctionner alors par exemple vous
raconter chacun des salles une sa
lunette pour les mètres carrés par
personne c'est dix mètres carrés par
famille par famille pardon je bats
langue a fourché vous raconter par
exemple que chacun avait sa lunette de
toilettes pour pas que ça soit les mêmes
avaient cru au nôtre voilà est à leur
portée alors commencer
chacun avait le sien d'abord les
réfrigérateurs sont arrivés vraiment
tard dans notre vie mais la cuisine est
aussi une cuisine communautaire avec des
tables des petites tables
chaque table appartient à chaque famille
et gare à celui qui qui ceux qui
s'aventurent sur l'étagère du voisin
c'est vraiment c'est très très bien tenu
en général sauf quand ça boit et sa voix
beaucoup et quand ça boit comme on
disait en russie pas de bons mariages
pas de mariage réussi sans castagne pas
de pas de vie commune pas de vie
conjugale réussissant castagne donc vous
imaginez que les dix familles qui
vivaient là bas voilà on était tous au
courant de ddd malheurs et des heures
des autres et et c'est aussi quelque
chose qui aujourd'hui comme comme je le
dis dans le livre finalement comme
toutes ces guerres dont on est revenu
vivant bas elles deviennent finalement
quelque chose d' extrêmement précieux et
constitue une force phénoménale
aujourd'hui j'ai la chance et je
considère cela vraiment comme une chance
quelle que soit la la vie que je puisse
mener aujourd'hui quel que soit le
palace où je peux séjourné au gré de de
ma vie bourgeoise parisienne
jamais ne me quitte ni l'odeur de notre
cuisine communautaire ni les voix qui
ont accompagné mes premières années de
vie
est ce qu'il y a de ce viatique en moi
pour revenir à votre question
et bien c'est ça c'est de savoir de
savoir exactement d'où je viens et cette
malle qui avait construit ma grand mère
dans laquelle j'ai dormi jusqu'à l'âge
de 12 ans et bien c'est c'est la couche
la plus confortable que j'ai connu et
aucun lit king size ne pourra la
remplacer
et ça donne un livre formidable que vous
avez intitulé suprême soviets et qui est
donc paru chez le pas d'oiseau avec une
préface
si vous moucher pas du coude comme on
dit avec une préface d'emmanuel carrère
c'est le pullman vous vous êtes
galeristes et vous publiez quelle mouche
l'a piqué chez flammarion
alors de quoi il s'agit exactement il
faut vous expliquer en fait il s'agit en
fait au départ c'étaient des chroniques
que je faisais à la radio art et quand
est arrivé l'histoire de la banane de
maurizio cattelan à miami où je me suis
rendu compte que finalement on ne
parlait que d'or que quand ça devenait
extrêmement méprisant pour le grand
public c'est à dire que vous vous sentez
votre erreur et que votre masque vous
allumez les infos et vous voyez que la
banane elle vaut 130 mines et puis qu'il
ya un mec a mordu dans non quelle base à
200 milles
je veux dire ça devient absolument un i
indigeste gien et donc vous vous êtes
amusé à caractériser tous les tous les
artistes renommés des 60 dernières
années et d'expliquer leurs spécificités
et chacun alors par exemple on va en
voir quelques uns ensemble jean michel
basquiat
il ya d'ailleurs à chaque fois une
oeuvre qui a été réinterprétée on voit
celle ci est ce qu'il ya derrière moi
basquiat pour vous c'est quoi qu'est-ce
qu'on peut expliquer aux gens pour leur
dire pourquoi
basquiat enfin plutôt ici où je reprends
votre formule
quelle mouche l'a piqué bas si vous
voulez base gay c'est un exemple super
personnel parce que moi je vivais à new
york entre 82 et 86
on a été très très très très amis et je
peux vous dire que quand ont passé un
moment dans un atelier 6-11 été regardé
en disant qu'un jour il y aura un
tableau qui ferait 110 millions je vous
promets exhaure eric ané sec c'est que
tout ça est devenu très fou quoi et en
fait l'idée de ce livre
déjà j'ai beaucoup et
l'idée qu'a eue ce cet illustrateur
merveilleux qu'est ce qu'ils appellent
lucas coskun qu'un quart dessiné toutes
les oeuvres y compris les photos ce qui
est assez marrant et est vraiment
c'était une espèce
l'idée c'est vraiment de dire eux dans
les médias on ne parle d'art que quand
il ya des artistes qui comptent des
poussins qui n'est ce pas être tokyo à
loreley de shit et qu'il y avait mon
courant on n'est que dans un système où
les institutions ont tellement peu de
moyens qu'elles sont obligées de lever
des sommes folles tous les mois comme le
ballet tokyo par act up et qui du coup
les oblige à présenter des gens qui
déclenche le journal de 20h c'est à dire
le canadien qu'elle couvait 26 bande en
26 jours et qu'il ya neuf points qui
naissent
mais je vous garantis que je dis des
arrivants pourront oui mais la juste
raison ganac qui figure dans votre livre
c'est ben il était dans cette émission
il n'y a pas très longtemps et ben lui
même a passé quasiment sa vie voilà un
ben ré ré interpréter c'est à dire que
c'est quasiment la même chose il a bel
et bien à passer sa vie je lui aussi a
essayé de 2-2-2 comment dire de
de classer les artistes par spécialité
puisqu'il appelle leur ego leur ego benz
qui est très injuste aussi dans la même
série que maurizio cattelan c'est que
gamble tout à coup créé cette espèce de
deux lignes de rentrée des classes où
tous les cahiers il ya écrit ceci est un
cahier et cellulaire dérivée du
merchandising et malheureusement si on
le regarde que par cet angle là c'est
d'une grande tristesse parce que c'est
un très grand artiste un artiste qui a
appartenu à un mouvement qui est un des
mouvements assez extraordinaire d'une
complexité folle qui s'appelle fluxus
et une fois de plus tout à coup on enfin
si vous voulez une idée de l'idée de ce
livre c'est vraiment de de réconcilier
le public avec là c'est à dire que tout
à coup les gens voient une oeuvre et au
lieu de voir le prix de l'heure et bien
ils voient que c'est un type normal
comme bertrand lavier qui quittaient le
visa d'un notaire 4 est bien amusé en
bourgogne qui décide de faire l'école
horticole et tous les jours ils passent
devant chez daniel d'emplois et la 18e
fois oui parce qu'il comprend qu'il est
artiste - c'est ça qui m'intéresse mais
yahia louise bourgeois qui y figure
évidemment pas remis et parmi les
artistes elle et elle est célèbre pour
ses araignées et vous dites qu'en fait
ces araignées c'est sa mère un louise
bourgeois une oeuvre totalement sexuel
qui a en plus qui c'est une femme
extraordinaire que j'ai eu la chance de
rencontrer avec ma mère et qui est en
fait son fils et juge à la cour suprême
c'est à dire que ça ratisse très large
et c'est vrai que les français ont
commencé à récupérer d'ailleurs le nom
est comique a décidé que c'était un
artiste française mais heureusement que
les américains s'en sont occupé parce
que c'est pas des six une artiste
française exporté chris burden qui est
pas très connu chris burden mais lui il
ya beaucoup beaucoup de choses à dire
parce que lui effectivement dans le
genre provocation genre je vais faire
des trucs est épouvantable inclassable
pour qu'on parle de moi il se pose là
alors lui il a commencé avec des
performances assez exagéré genre tiré
sur un 747 qui décolle de los angeles
airport genre se faire tirer dans le
bras par un de ses meilleurs amis
enfin bon il ya eu un moment comme ça
très et ensuite il s'est mis à faire des
oeuvres donc l'oeuvre qui illustré dans
le livre qui cette oeuvre sublime qui ce
rouleau compresseur qui pèse 40 tonnes
et donc vous avez le type qui au volant
du rouleau compresseur le truc se met à
tourner doucement avec le moteur du
rouleau compresseur et commis un espèce
de bras qui compense
du coup vous avez le mec qui te le
moteur et là vous avez ce rouleau
compresseur qui s'envole et vous
entendez que le bruit du vent c'est
sublime
il avait des oeuvres extra moi j'ai suis
lg nuit il démarre n'est qu'une femme
artiste extraordinaire il avait posé un
avion qui avait fait semblant de se
crasher sur le toit de leur maison et
ils avaient 7 vrigny qui est
l'inventaire de tous les tableaux de
guerre américains en balsa ou de verre
ces espèces de forme complètement
difforme avec des trains électriques
enfin c'est un type fantastique autres
autres grands imaginatif sevim delevoye
on va alors son amour des cochons et
légendaire bien entendu vous avez
représenté le cochon vous auriez pu
représenter la machine à caca qui est
assez américain et moi vous tous uniques
oui mais elle est comme elle est très
représentatif de de l'oeuvre jean paul
delevoye puisqu'il est arrivé à personne
si fine on lui fait rentrer un repas et
au bout de quelques heures il en ressort
du caca ouais vous m'aidez le steak
tartare à gauche et à droite sans le
gros seront au bout du temps qu'ils y
mot celui de la digestion humaine mais
il ya aussi des artistes plus classiques
comme le le peintre britannique lucian
freud le petit fils de sigmund voilà
voilà un type qui est un peu d'être des
plus classiques pas trop figuratif rien
à voir avec l'art contemporain
ah non non mais en mai dans la grande
peinture anglaise
c'est comme francis bacon quoi céder
d'ailleurs ils ont collaboré ces des
immenses pins et là où la chose et aussi
folles et c'est quand même bien de le
dire c'est que un type comme francis
bacon il a été super cher à la première
seconde serre que c'est là que l'art est
une chose folle parce que quand des gens
ont la naïveté de vous demander des
conseils
c'est ya aucune règle et en même temps
toutes les routes mènent à rome
stengel on ne peut rien conseiller a
personne pour devenir artiste et lui
jaser fantastique quand on a un bagage
qui quand même on peut dire du super lot
d'arriver à trouver un langage et
gilbert gilles beranger jh je fis sont
assez connus on l'est on les voit
toujours dans le les mêmes costumes de
représentant de commerce
alors oui leur spécificité c'est quoi
leur art a eu l'art de gilbert en
giorgio ballot c'est à dire que leur art
du début était une espèce de nouvelles
pistes et qu'ensuite c'est devenu bas
comme plein d'artistes quand ils font
quelque chose et c'est pour ça que les
artistes il ya deux catégories ceux qui
font quelque chose qui tuent des coûts
se met soudainement à marcher et qui
sont prêts à arrêter ça pour continuer
leur projet au lieu de devenir de
factory offre que les gens aiment eux
malheureusement ils sont plutôt dans la
catégorie de ceux qui qui ont beaucoup
répéter ce qu'ils avaient faisait au
début il ya edward hopper que les
français adorent
parce que c'est toute une image un peu
de staël gic de l'amérique
edward hopper vous dites que pour le
comprendre il faut savoir d'abord qu'il
a vécu à paris et que quand il est
revenu aux états unis ça a été pénible
pour lui
deuxièmement qu'il détestait son métier
d'illustrateur et troisièmement qu'il
avait une femme infecte très
antipathique 13,1 sur zone arctique
le type qui se plante sur tout sauf sur
son travail mais ils passeront enfin et
pas très loin du strass ion mais c'est
un génie la peinture mais il n'était pas
très bon pas trop non plus d'ailleurs
à la fin c'est ben ça donne des toiles
très intéressante mais c'est pas très
bon peintre non non non non non c'est
pas un très bon pote mais c'est un très
beau transcripteur d'ambiance c'est à
dire que l'agglo qui tude du bar elle
est absolument sincère et très bien
reproduite
ça s'appelle quelle mouche l'a piqué
c'est le nouveau livre de cyril pittman
qui vient de paraître chez flammarion je
vous remercie d'avoir participé à cette
émission je vous remercie tous les trois
et merci de nous avoir suivis par la
même occasion et et rendez vous au
prochain numéro